you ever seen him on spine that's enough
boys never seen a smile my love
she'sa colleges
it's great
besides me
lessons she knows what to do with time
in love with
she
and
- yeah
you
sorry
oh sorry
got a girl but she sounds no bad
and everyone stay
I got two missing
every single sound sighs yeah
yes
that
yeah
so if you're new here and you just came
to watch been folders new video hello
recently he sent me an email just saying
do you want to make a music video for
one of my songs and I was like yeah this
is the first time I've ever had a budget
for a music video so you can probably
tell just from that that I'm pretty new
when it comes to making music videos for
people but I had a lot of fun making it
I'm very happy with the outcome and
hopefully you liked it as well to give
credit where credit is due thank you to
Tom bacon also known as bacon cam for
doing all of the filming for that little
music video and also thank you to Alex
days hands for holding the glass and
spinning me around in my spinny chair oh
this is scary sir thank you everyone for
continuing to support my online
etiquette aids cuz if it wasn't for you
I wouldn't get to do fun stuff like this
so thank you and I see you around
or not wherever bye you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool
I broke the saucepan oops the daisies